well joining us now is deputy leader of
the labour party angela rainer hello to
you ms rainey thanks for joining us i
suppose oh yes you're stuck between a
rock and a hard place this morning
aren't you because you're glad to see
what happened to boris johnson but you
i'm guessing you want him to stay in
post now until an election
no i don't want boris johnson to stay in
post because as you know many of the
public see politicians in general as uh
untrustworthy and i think boris johnson
is pulling down the standards in public
life which is why we've got the motion
today to uphold them but i think he he's
doing a very disservice to the country
and it's pretty clear now that the
british public have lost all confidence
in boyce johnson i mean if you can't
have a prime minister that follows his
own rules and doesn't lie to parliament
and lie to the british public then where
is the standards you know we've lowered
the tone so bad that um you know we
could get away with just about anything
so i don't think it's a good day i think
he is mortally wounded now and i think
that you know he's he's only got an 80
of majority within parliament and
therefore he's pretty clear that over 70
percent of his backbenchers didn't back
him so i think he should have done the
right thing by now and resigned already
but this prime minister doesn't really
consider himself to follow rules but
don't you want a wounded prime minister
in position while you sort your party
out
and no i think you know our party
obviously in 2019 in the general
election lost badly and i think since
myself and care have taken over we've
been making steady progress if you'd
have said we are where we are today
back then i think most people would have
laughed at us but we know we've got work
to do but i think you know when you've
got a prime minister who lies to the
british public who breaks his rules i
mean number 10 was the most heavily
fined building a house in the whole of
the united kingdom when it came to the
covid rules cleaners were having to
clean up vomit and wind off the walls i
mean it wasn't
a one-off this was serial partying going
on in number 10 when people couldn't see
their loved ones i don't think it's
going away i think every day that boris
johnson is prime minister is damaging
the standards in public life and it
damages us all so i don't think it's a
good thing that he continues i think
he's arrogant i think he's dismissive i
think he's a liar and i don't think he
should hold the office of prime minister
yeah but you you as a party are still
not ready to run the country are you
i think we are i think we've shown that
actually when you look at the issues
that people are facing at the moment
whether that's the cost of living the
travel chaos whether that's the
situation with the nhs we've got the
answers to those uh damaging questions
that people are asking at the moment
boris johnson is too busy naval gazing
looking after himself to look at the
issues that many working people as this
country are facing at the moment and
that's damaging for people because you
know while rather than saving and
supporting people that need that help
now
that vote for us boris johnson is trying
to save his own skin
but how can you be ready when the leader
and the deputy leader are still facing a
police inquiry
well because you see here's the
difference with the police inquiry on
that occasion when we were in work we're
very confident that we were working and
we said categorically if we were issued
with a fixed penalty notice we would
resign because standards in public life
matter it might have be on me it might
be on care and it might be on boris
johnson he broke the rules that he set
and he's decided that he those rules
don't apply to him i think it's damaging
for the public because you know if he
breaks those rules and lies to the
public now what else is he going to lie
about you know he's bringing everyone
down i think that's the issue here and
the big difference is that there is one
investigation into one work event that
we're very confident that will be
uh will be fine and if it isn't we've
said categorically that we shouldn't
carry on in post i think the prime
minister over 120 fixed penalty notices
numerous parties going on in number 10
and he's had a fixed penalty notice and
he doesn't think he should resign i
think that's appalling
but facts are facts aren't they and the
leader and the deputy leader of the
opposition have both been received
questionnaires so in other words
question of police caution and they
still have a police investigation
outstanding you're not ready you can't
run the country yet while you're in that
position
well yeah of course we can you know
we're very ready to do that we've been
talking about the issues that matter to
people like the windfall tax on the
energy companies to support people to
look at a renewable energy programme
that creates jobs in this country and
deals with our long-term energy needs to
have a new deal for working people that
provides
flexibility and work that pays for
people we've got a programme for change
and we're getting on with that and we're
very clear that if the police found us
to be guilty and give us a fixed penalty
notice we would resign we're very
confident that we didn't break the rules
and that we followed all the rules to
the letter
well that's rolling the dice isn't it
and that's putting the party the labour
party in jeopardy because if that did
happen and you don't know if it will or
not if it did and you were in the middle
of a general election campaign say the
prime minister calls a snap election
then the leader and the deputy leader
would have to step down what would that
do for the uh credibility of the party
but i don't think it's rolling the dice
i think it's called doing the right
thing i think there has to be a standard
a line that is drawn between the
contract of the british public and those
that hold public office it's an honor
and a privilege to have the roles that
myself and care have got and we know
that we do that um with the
goodwill of our party and with the
people that voted for us as mps we're
saying that if we broke the rules we
would resign we would not carry on boris
johnson says it doesn't matter and
there's laughed in people's faces and
lied to them when they couldn't see
their loved ones now if myself and kid
did resign we're not the only people in
the labour party we're a team we work
together in the labour party and have
done that and we work in the interests
of the public unlike boris johnson who
is a bit of a
tim pop uh dictator now who thinks he
could just carry on regardless anyway i
was broken his own rules and he's not
listening he's lost the confidence of
the british public and he's now lost the
confidence of many of his mps is limping
on because he doesn't think the rules
apply to him and i think he's gonna he's
gonna find out pretty
clear through the by-elections that
actually the british public do not like
liars people who break the rules and i
think it's going to be very damaging for
his party and for politics in general if
the prime minister carries on
timbuktu tin pot dictator that's very
strong uh words there from you this
morning ms rainer will the labour party
be calling for a vote of no confidence
in the whole cup in the whole government
well today we've set out a motion which
is about upholding standards in public
life which boris johnson again wants to
cherry-pick that the chair have been
very clear that the whole report should
be implemented and we agree with that so
we've put motion down today to ensure
that we at least set a bar that is
higher than where boris johnson is
so that we can you know restore some
trust in public office and of course
we'll look at all options going forward
but you know the prime minister ignores
he should have resigned months ago he
knows he broke the law he knows he lied
to the british public but you know he'll
just keep limping on because he doesn't
think the rules apply to him and he's
laughing at the general public and
taking them for fools and i think most
of the public will not move on while
boris johnson is prime minister
and in answer to my question will you be
calling for a vote of no confidence in
the whole government
well we'll see how we go on for the rest
of the week obviously we'll speak to
other
other parties as well but we're very
clear that the prime minister doesn't
have the confidence of the house pretty
clear from the votes of his own mps that
he's lost a lot of significant
confidence within his own political
party and if he had an ounce of
integrity which he removed from the code
he would have resigned by now